i'd like to
begin by thanking andy and dennis for
inviting me to speak today
my first few paragraphs are addressed
to the student body
and then i'm actually going to read from
my book
the intuition that scientific inquiry in
the methods of pure mathematics may yet
lead us
into the light of certainty is to be
trusted
the doubts of the past century have led
us to a crisis that undermines
the scientific endeavor
despite the disquieting failures of
modern logical methods
we must regain our confidence cease to
be enamored of our successes
and accept the challenges that remain
for us to succeed however
requires that we better understand the
relationship between the disciplines
of pure mathematics and the physical
sciences
most of all it requires
that we be bold sustained by humility
we must maintain a fear of dogma and
have the courage not only to challenge
intellectual taboos but our own
intellectual investments
there is great difficulty in pursuing
basic research
that must by necessity take you from the
comfort of consensus
into the realms of our collective
ignorance and
false interpretations the great advances
of one civilization over another
does not arise in the inevitable
application
of new discoveries investments of a few
years or months
in the developments of new technologies
offers only a transitory advantage
and the comfort of security to a
temporary elite
they are the trinkets of basic discovery
great advances and great civilizations
arise from the deeper understanding
that requires both the liberty of
intellectual pursuit
and time neither are dependent upon
private funding nor government ground
they are the sole product of the human
spirit
the independent mind and the defining
commitment of the inquirer
i read now from my forthcoming book on
the origin
of experience there is a broader
historical context here
that i can present today and i now
only mention it briefly
in it we find a precedence for the
treatment of logic as a natural science
whose mandate is to build the bridge
between
pure mathematics and the physical
sciences
this view was clearly articulated by the
great american mathematician
benjamin purse the father of charles
sanders purse
and james mills purse the circumstances
are those of the 19th century
that saw the development of scientific
inquiry and higher education
in the usa the narrative occurs
especially around the birth of harvard
university
it is to be regretted that the majority
of you here will not know
of these circumstances or these names
this period has nonetheless informed
america's greatest minds
and i have come to call it the american
enlightenment
a deferral defense of this narrative to
my lecture on january 15th
in this forum on the life and work of
charles sanders purse
who died in 1914
i also regret that i do not have the
time here to relate
the mathematical approach i describe to
the evidence in biophysics
or to walk through the mathematical
details present in the book
my content selection that amounts to the
opening pages
is intended to provide an accessible
overview of the approach
however as a punchline i will write the
equations i described on the blackboard
i will read until approximately 5 15 and
then take questions
i have no doubt that in this forum you
will have questions concerning my
exclusion of touring computation from
biophysics
those are not adequately covered in this
content
i will be happy to defend this position
at the time
i hope also to get questions that relate
to the practical implications of the
ideas presented
their implications to machine
engineering and medicine for example
the book is entitled
on the origin of experience the shaping
of sense
and the complex world and it begins with
a quote from benjamin purse
that reads in every form of material
manifestation
there is a corresponding form of human
thought
so that the human mind is as wide in its
range of thought
as the physical universe in which it
thinks
but how are we to explain the presence
of our experience in the world and its
many forms
this book is the product of a research
journey to answer these questions
that begins for me in the corridors of
the university of arizona
in conversations with the mathematician
roger penrose
in march of 2003 we participated in a
meeting
that asked whether advances in quantum
mechanics
and biophysics informed us concerning
the nature of the mind
relying primarily on the work of kurt
godel
and alan turing penrose argues that a
mathematical solution to the problem
describing experience in nature is
impossible
well precisely he says the solution
deals
with the non-computable
it has always been my intuition however
that the limits of logical description
that he refers to are not limits of the
world
or failures of mathematics in general
they are rather indications of a failure
in the foundations of mathematical logic
they are failures of a particular method
it seemed to me therefore most likely
resolution could be found by an inquiry
into the nature of computation
i am especially concerned that the
immediate
continuous transformation of structure
as holistically conceived by a
mathematician
and evident throughout biophysics is not
reflected naturally
in any of turing's methods of systematic
computation
this fact passes unnoticed at the scale
of computing familiar to most of us
and this has seduced many to believe
that computation
is invincible but it is now
clear that
the efficiency of the turing computation
decreases as the problem size increases
with physically limiting consequences at
large scales
these consequences will ultimately lead
me
to exclude turin's models of computation
from biophysics as a keen scholar
of recent biophysical results funding
for other causes
often far from basic research
i had long suspected that the attempt to
mathematize biophysics
promised to inform the foundations of
logic
it seemed to me impossible for
biophysics to make progress
without an exact account of experience
as sense and so as i listened to
penrose's ideas and concerns
a contrary approach to the problem came
to mind
my approach then is simple to state
it is to ask what methods
are required to enable a mathematical
description
of the different forms of sense how they
are modified
and the role that these actions play in
the operation
of biophysical structure sense in this
case
is simply the variety of experience
specifically the goal of such an
approach
is to illustrate how a particular
sensation
is formed and modified in biophysical
structure
and the role that this action plays in
the selection and performance
of directed and non-directed response
and further to describe how this basic
mechanism combines
to construct the entire experience of
individuals
and the operations of the familiar mind
such an approach is the first step
toward reasoning about
many forms of sense its place in nature
and in the considerations of physical
science
it leads us to ask what may be missing
from our physical conceptions
and models of mathematical computation
with respect to these conventions it
asks
what remains for the living mind
in addressing this question i illustrate
in exact terms
how my solution takes its place in the
physical sciences
the purpose here is to present the
theory in sufficient detail to a broad
audience
across disciplines it includes the
mathematical framework
of the theory and its immediate
implications to physical
to physics in general logic and
computation
as a consequence i treat logic as a
natural science
whose mandate is to build the bridge
between pure mathematics
and the physical sciences
new section entitled experience as
sense
i begin by clarifying and stating
informally
it is clearly as i may the subject that
concerns us
it is the origin of experience
its formation and shaping as sense
and the role that this action plays in
biophysical mechanics
it is the shaping of all complexity when
i speak of a complex world
i speak of biophysics in particular and
also more generally
the formation and behaviors of the
living world and all that derives from
it
what is experience it is certainly the
senses
and ideas that are forced upon us by the
world
but this view alone is insufficient for
experience is equally found
in the sensations and ideas that we
force upon the world
by our actions more generally
experience then is that which is most
familiar
it is common to all sense
when i speak of experience as sense
i speak of its variety in individuals
these experiences include the textbook
senses
vision the sense of aroma
touch taste and sound
it includes the experience of pain that
turns
out to be an entirely independent and
specialized central sensory system
it includes the sense of ourself
and the behaviors over which we may have
the power of beta
it is then in the most general terms
in our anticipations recognitions
and actions it includes all that we
speak of as thinking
intuition and emotion as forms of
internal sense
this is the experience of our own
structure and its operation
ideas feelings and passions of all kinds
are such experiences
experience dominates our actions
and is modified by our physical form
we are each aware that our experience
and behaviors
are modified by the physical effects
of trauma sickness and intoxication
our decisions concerning how we move
about the world
where we locate ourselves with whom we
share our lives
our pleasures and our discomforts
are dominated by the entirety of our
continuing experience
i will also assume that it is
by the necessity of the uh mathematical
approach
present in the varieties of scents not
seen in our species
for example in the sensory and
responsive mechanisms
of plants and other organisms
now let me be clear i am not suggesting
that the form of sensory experience in
plants and bacteria
is anything that we would recognize as
our own
the experience of each species has a
unique form
nor am i going to suggest that inanimate
objects
think and feel i'm simply saying
that if we are to develop a mathematical
foundation
for a general theory of biophysics
all sensory and responsive behavior
must be given the same basis
there are two principal factors that
distinguish biophysics
from the inanimate world the first is
that sense and response
are bound in the function of flexible
closed
structures such as you and i
the second is that the basis of these
functions
the basis of experience
is a universal effect in such structures
and so it is that the challenge here
is to determine the role that of that
effect
in exact terms i'm aware that many of
you including some fellow scientists
still consider experience to be the
exclusive domain of our species
our intelligent behavior does in many
ways
exceed that of other organisms
that have appeared upon our planet
this capacity for higher intelligence is
no doubt enhanced
by factors other than experience
these factors allow us to succeed where
other species
that may well have a richer natural
experience
do not i'm thinking here
of creatures such as dolphins whose
brain
we may argue uh exhibits
a greater refinement and sophistication
of structure than our own
the factors that give us advantage
include our capacity to finally
manipulate
physical objects and record
our capacity for literature and our
ability to develop
and conduct scientific inquiry
over generations
this advantage is confirmed by our
surprising ability
to manipulate the world such that we may
imbue machines
with aspects of this intelligence
but that this is indeed the case says
nothing at all
about experience it provides no cause
for the assumption that other organisms
do not share it
new section entitled what the world is
and how we may speak of it
the epistemic cause what the world is
and how we may speak of it finds great
advantage
in the development of pure mathematics
indifferent to the acts of physical
science
pure mathematics is the science that
draws necessary conclusions
from premises of any kind
yet it is the judge over all of our
ideas
and physical science may not be
indifferent to it
in the epistemology i present i will
speak of necessary distinctions and ways
of speaking
a necessary distinction is a distinction
that we force upon the world
while a way of speaking is a distinction
that the world
forces upon us
in other words many of our conceptual
devices in science
and elsewhere are free inventions of the
mind
that enable us to speak about the world
the world itself however is free of such
devices
except in this form these basic concepts
are fundamental to both the biophysics
of experience
and the epistemology presented i avoid
the vernacular ways of speaking about
the epistemic cause with some
deliberateness
i later provide a more general theory of
knowledge and information
than that which is typically found
new section how to mathematically
characterize
a sense at this point allow me without
further ceremony
to address the most significant question
that arises from the discussion so far
how exactly may we characterize
experience as sense
it is perhaps surprising that the
epistemic considerations
mathematical devices advocated by
einstein
provides the way forward i will refine
einstein's approach
in order to meet my goal this requires
however
that i defend einstein from well-known
criticisms
in the literature that are yet to be
resolved definitively
i will also need to make my use of this
approach
clear my use of this approach clear with
respect
to modern theoretical physics and
biochemistry
i briefly state the case here in terms
that are
perhaps familiar i elaborate and clarify
as we go
if you have more than the passing
understanding of general relativity
as i hope many of my readers do then the
following states the case plainly
later i provide an exact formulation
however we have some groundwork to cover
before i do
as a word of caution i must note that
the modern presentation the general
relativity
that often neglects the epistemic
questions
may not serve our understanding here
i rely primarily on einstein's original
writings
on the foundations of general relativity
published in german in 1916
and his writings in the period
immediately following
there are two central components to
einstein's view
the first is the equivalence principle
that in its naive forms simply states
that inertial
and gravitational mass are equivalent
further after some consideration of this
principle
we get affirmation of a universal unity
such that all the laws of nature have a
single source
this leads to an important question
however concerning the nature of this
source the essence of nature
and how to speak of it
it is in the light of these
considerations that einstein advocates
that all the laws of nature are to be
characterized
in a generally covariant form
he says the general laws of nature
are to be expressed by equations that
hold good for all systems of coordinates
that is our covariant with respect to
any substitution whatsoever
this is his definition of generally
covariant
the epistemic consequence of this view
is immediately recognized by einstein
it is that space-time is to be isolated
to its epistemic cause
as einstein puts in this requirement of
general covariance
takes away from space and time the last
remnant of physical objectivity
in other words space and time are to be
simply treated
as convenient ways of speaking about the
behavior
and structure of the world independent
of considerations of essence
my agreement with einstein will lead me
to advocate a form of structuralism
this view simply states that the subject
of both pure mathematics
and the physical sciences is structure
pure mathematics and the physical
sciences are to be considered to have
the same subject therefore
if logic is a natural science is to be
is to build the bridge between the two
its subject
must also be founded upon this
structuralism
this acceptance of general covariance is
the basis
of a logical and mathematical
construction of the world recognizes the
limits of discovery
if nature may be fully described by the
effects
of covariant essential properties
then the basis of these distinctions
the essence of the subject is
inaccessible
except by our direct experience of the
world
as its part this
is then the direction that i pursue
by it i am able to describe the
mathematical framework
of a physical theory in which the
essential properties of nature
include the basis of experience and
provide
a general theory of biophysics
that includes the effect of this basis
as sense
in addition to the formation and
operation of all biophysical structure
new section experience as
an essential property of the world
the goal of such a formulation is then
not only
to enable a means to characterize a
particular sense
and its developing response potentials
but also to characterize basic and
complex biophysical functions of all
kinds
this includes the formation of of
receptor clusters
and motor functions upon the surfaces of
cells
it includes the basic functions of cell
division
and more generally how biochemistry and
biophysical structure work together
it includes the collaborative action of
cells and cell types
it includes the action and sensation
of musculature and the collaboration
between astrocytes and neurons
in the brain a successful formulation
will allow us to consider the behavior
of organisms of all kinds
from simple bacteria to whales
so it should be clear that i propose a
single effect
that acts throughout biophysics
one that will not only explain what
remains for the living mind
but that will also explain the beating
heart
and clearly i must account for why it is
that the common basis of these diverse
behaviors
have different experiential
characteristics
why it is the heart continues by the
same means
but rarely intrudes upon the unity of
our immediate experience
and why it is that these actions are not
adequately explained by known biophysics
for some readers it will no doubt be
clear at this point where i'm headed
this unification of a broad range of
diverse
observed behaviors by a single
conception
is familiar to all that no science
it is precisely the discovery of isaac
newton
that is so ably refined by the work of
einstein
am then to propose a single universal
essential property
that has many of the characteristics of
gravitation
indeed it is a sibling of gravitation
an essential property of the world
and while the effect of gravitation is
most evident
in the open structures of the world
the effect of this essential property is
seen in the flexible closed structures
of the world
such as you and i it is for this reason
that we are informed by einstein's
epistemology
einstein would enjoy this approach for
its simplicity
it is exactly the kind of simplicity he
often spoke of
new section entitled building on
einstein
i have no doubt that some readers will
immediately ask
how i may justify taking a mathematical
construction concerning the universal
effect of gravitation
and apply the very same techniques to
the difficult question
of experience in nature and associated
behaviors in biophysics
there is a more general question here
concerning how it is that mathematics is
so unreasonably
effective such that its forms may be
applied throughout the natural sciences
address the relevance of this question
in more detail later
but briefly it is simply that the world
maintains a profound uniformity
and this uniformity is evident in the
discovery
that pure mathematics remains effective
independent of scale
so it is that mathematics of general the
mathematics of general relativity may
also be applied to biophysics
for the same reason the adjustment of
scale in physics
called renormalization is an effective
technique
it is also why small-scale machine
computation
maintains a useful effectiveness despite
its practical limits at large scales
the efficiency of computation is not
scaling variant
and we will discover that this is the
primary distinction
between computation as we understand it
today
and the natural computation of the
familiar mind
if our purely mathematical tools however
did not demonstrate this effectiveness
then the world does not possess possess
the profound uniformity
upon which science relies
in addition i will rely on this scaling
variance
to reason about sense in the large and
small
it is for example why i almost twice the
mass of my wife
have in all important respects the same
experience
and capacities as she
however i must note that einstein's
epistemology is rarely given the
consideration that it deserves
it has been subjected to some division
einstein was exhausted
in its defense and it is entirely
ignored by quantum theory
its broader impact is unappreciated
even by the intimate friends and
admirers of einstein
including kurt godel and rudolph carnap
this is rather unfortunate because in
their own inquiry
is exactly what they were looking for
meeting resistance and in order to
communicate effectively his primary
physical ideas
einstein frequently diluted his
epistemic statements
in the great cause this difficulty
is compounded by the fact that he does
not rigorously
apply his advocated epistemology to the
formulation of his equations
if einstein made an error in general
relativity
then it is that his equations do not
speak clearly of space-time curvature
in a way that is consistent with the
epistemology he advocated
this led quickly to the accusation that
his
theory is physically vacuous
the dominant materialist view in which
mata
has epistemic primacy
naturally led people to see einstein's
gravitation
as the product of matter and to ignore
the full implications of the equivalence
principle
it is in fact not that gravitation
is the curvature of a an existent space
time
but rather that the effects and
the effect an essential property of
nature may be
conveniently spoken of as space-time
curvature
despite what now may be viewed as the
penetrating clarity
of his epistemic stance
einstein thought of himself as a type of
unscrupulous
optimist on the subject
in his later years he put it this way
science without epistemology is in so
far as it is thinkable at all
primitive and muddled however
the scientist accepts gratefully the
epistemological conceptual analysis
but the external conditions which are
set
by the facts of experience do not permit
too much restriction in the construction
of the conceptual world
einstein continues the scientists
therefore must
appear to the systematic epistemologist
as a type of unscrupulous opportunist
he appears as a realist insofar as he
seeks to describe the world
independent of the acts of perception
as idealist insofar as he looks upon the
concepts and theories
as free inventions of the human spirit
not logically derived from what is
empirically given
as positivist in so far as he considers
his concepts
and theories justified only to the
extent
to which they furnish a logical
representation
of relations among sensory experiences
einstein was aged 80 at the time he gave
this response
so it is that by this time more than 30
years
after the publication of general
relativity he claimed his victories
and the epistemic cause was one he no
longer chose to fight
it is my impression that he was simply
exhausted
by the defense of his epistemological
ideas
in the face of a stubborn materialism
perpetuated by quantum theory
the epistemic battle over general
relativity
centered upon the physical basis of
gravitation
since einstein claimed that space-time
is to be restricted to its epistemic
cause
this immediately presents the question
of what it is
that gravitation has an effect upon
what can it be and he concluded but the
real existence
of space and time and this is where the
confusion arises
i propose a simple and perhaps naive
solution to this problem that will no
doubt be controversial
but as the english say in for a penny
in for a pound the embrace
of einstein's 1916 epistemology
has interesting consequences for the
formulation
of physics in general and the foundation
of mathematics
it will enable me to place the basis of
experience
and the study of experience as sense
in exact terms in the physical sciences
by reformulating einstein's equations to
meet the strictest application
of his advocated epistemology the
arising structuralism
suggests provocative solutions
it will also lead me to argue that this
structuralism
founded upon a unity of premises
suggested by einstein's general
covariance
is to be preferred in general over the
normal axiomatic method
my restatement of general relativity
does indeed isolate space-time to its
epistemic course
it also provides an obvious unification
of the principal equations of special
and general relativity
and provides an account of light as the
physical basis upon which gravitate the
gravitational effect
rests
so i trust that i will be forgiven my
own unscrupulous opportunism
as a systematic epistemologist
in order to illustrate my cause
in defending einstein i will take this
liberty
and buy it offer a plausible
reinterpretation of physical results
in this cause i rewrite the einstein
equations
in a way that allows me to illustrate
exactly how
a complete theory of biophysics may be
incorporated
into the physical sciences in addition
this formulation will serve to
illustrate how the structuralism i
propose may be broadly applied
this methodological illustration
of how a theory of experience may be
included in the physical sciences is my
sole purpose
it is not my goal to propose a grand
theory
and although i must take this excursion
through cosmology
my focus is the biophysical matters at
hand
and the characterization the mechanics
involved
that must eventually include
biochemistry
new section entitled
the mathematical and physical approach
to summarize that
as einstein advocated the conception of
space-time is to be isolated to its
epistemic course
it is a convenient way of speaking about
the generally covariant effects
of nature's essential properties
the essential properties of the world
are to be identified
and their effect in the world is to be
characterized as generally covariant
further following einstein
all the laws of nature are to be of this
form
and all of its constants are to be so
derived
our mathematical and physical subject is
then structure
and matters of essence must be deferred
to our experience of the world as its
path
by this means i can speak of a universal
basis of experience
as an essential property and its
covariant effect throughout the world
of special interest is the effect of
this basis
in the flexible closed structures of
biophysics
where the effect is manifest as sense
and biophysical response
it is the formation of flexible closed
structures
that makes critical uses of the
essential effects
in biophysical structure and is these
effects
that form sense and response
indeed by this formulation biophysics
becomes
the general mathematical science of
flexible closed
structures in their composition
let me clearly state now with the
foolish justification to follow the
essential properties of the world by
this formulation
the gravitational effect is readily
accepted
in this role and is well justified by
general relativity
in my reformulation of einstein's
equations
i interpret the constant measure of
light
to adequately justify a claim that light
does not
in fact move while there is indeed a
covariant effect between matter and
gravitation
gravitation is able to self-generate
the effects of einstein's equations
suggest
despite of the absence of matter
it will be important for us to consider
the end cases
involved this will allow us to recover
quantum theory
although we require a quite different
cosmology
it is only the light field free of
gravitational effect that can be said to
be without mass
the remainder of the world is composed
of gravitational mass
and inertial structure
this idea is counter intuitive to the
modern mind
rays to interpret light itself to have
motion
but this result may be directly derived
from the equivalence principle
and einstein's equations
let me emphasize that i have not set out
here to rewrite physics
or to propose a grand theory there's my
purpose here only to follow
the necessary conclusions of einstein's
methods
in order to illustrate how a complete
theory of biophysics
including experience as sense may be
formed
having now spent some time with the idea
myself i find it compelling
it explains why light is constant and
without mass
and it should come as no surprise that
all the forces of nature
may be unified by a conception of light
mathematically it may be considered a
field that is
a universal constant upon which the
gravitational effect can act
in speaking of light as a velocity we
are merely referring to the motion
of inertial mass within the light field
and we are not speaking of light itself
i show how this view is suggested by
einstein's equations
when strictly combined combined with his
advocated epistemology
by this new interpretation light is to
be considered
a constant finite field that takes the
place
of any conception of an existential
space time in the field equations
of general relativity or motion within
this field is that
of structures containing inertial mass
moving within it
or measured mass is to be considered to
have
a value unified by the equivalence
principle
it is always the combination of
intrinsic mass
determined by structure and
gravitational mass
and this will turn out to be disruptive
to our notions in quantum theory
but my goal is to speak in the very
simplest terms
however i will seek reconciliation with
quantum theory by treating it as a
second order consideration
as structure structure that has arisen
from the simplest albeit impossible
ideal state
this ideal state one of the cases that i
refer to above
is impossible because there is no
circumstance
in which we may consider the total
absence of the gravitational effect
by this i mean that the gravitational
effect
as characterized by general relativity
and now upon the proposed light field
produces all mass energy in its variety
of forms
in structure the light field may now be
substituted
into the field equations of general
relativity
it replaces the conception of an
existent space type
that may yet be retained for its
epistemic course
it is then structure bearing mass energy
that moves through this field and
wherever there is a gravitational effect
there is gravitational mass
a distortion of the light field
from the standpoint of our current
quantum theories this simply says
that all particles have mass and that
their intrinsic mass
is a function of their structure and
their measured mass is a function of
their
intrinsic and gravitational mass
combined
with this step we can unify the
well-known equations
of special relativity the equation of
mass
energy equivalence with the
gravitational field equations
such that we can determine the mass
energy value
of any point quantified by the actual
quantity
or area of distortion of the light
involved
this is difficult enough let me note
in keeping with my primary subject that
when i speak of
difficulty i'm always speaking of the
absence of familiarity
and this idea of the constant and
unmoving light field
is certainly unfamiliar
i will be surprised however to discover
that it is novel
i have little doubt that it can be found
somewhere hidden
in the private language of theoretical
physics
for it is an obvious and literal
interpretation of the equations
that include light as a constant
more difficult is now the claim that the
basis of experience is of equal standing
that it too is an essential property of
the world
so let me be clear while the
gravitational effect is evident
primarily in the open structure of the
world
the effect of the basis of experience is
evident
in the flexible closed structures of the
world
these flexible closed structures are the
cells and membranes
of biophysical structure they are
organisms
such as you and i these flexible closed
structure
exist in environments in which
all things being equal gravitation plays
places constraints but does not disrupt
the construction and action of these
structures
similarly the basis of experience cannot
be said to produce the familiar
characteristics
of biophysics sense and response
in environments or structures
other than this by this conception
i take the equivalence principle
seriously as an indicator that nature
has just one source
for all of its effects and the
properties of this source
are these distinctions gravitation
light and the basis of experience
of course i appear to have left a
familiar subject
unanswered this is where matter fits
into this model
here matter that can be accepted
where that we may accept is a subject
described why
quantum theory is a second order
consideration
in other words all mass energy in all of
its forms
is the product of the gravitational
effect upon the light field
it is derived from gravitational mass
i give the mathematical account of this
later
briefly once again this approach
provides us with a route into the
standard model of physics and classical
forces
for now let it be sufficient for me to
say that all structure
and all of its behaviors including those
of biophysics
arise from the generally covariant
effects of nature's essential properties
we will learn much concerning the
structure of the universe by considering
the end cases
of the gravitational effect according to
this model
the extreme case of the gravitational
effect in
einstein's terms characterized by the
greatest possible curvature of
space-time
produces a well-known event the black
hole this then
provides the circumstances in which
structure
appears in the world is initiated and
from which all matter
is derived it should be clear
that this view is contrary to the
conventional view
and makes puts that puts matter first
and it makes matter
the source of the gravitational effect
this model takes the inverse position
but with this exception and the revised
cosmology
the rest of physics stays intact
so this is the model that i wish to
mathematically characterize
much as einstein did i prefer the very
simplest mathematics
the universal effects of the essential
properties
are to be characterized as a covariant
tensor field
much as we do in general relativity
today however
in the case of the basis of experience
dealing with these
that with the effect of this field in
flexible closed
structure i make use of holomorphic
functors
and hyperfunctors to speak of the effect
of this field in sense and response
these are holistic structures that act
at once and together
under the unifying effect of the
essential basis
and they will allow me to reason about
biophysical behaviors in general
and then it is within this framework
that i must devise the means to reason
about biochemistry
also
i consider the formulation of these
factors in terms
of modern complex analysis and
an experimental geometry that may better
suit the task
in the second volume of this series i
compare these approaches in detail
it's worth observing that at the point
observing at this point that einstein
himself spent a good
deal of time 40 years is claimed
developing complex analysis as means of
unification
the less formal terms in less formal
terms
this mathematical model allows me to
speak of the shaping of sense
upon the surface of flexible closed
structures
or composites of substructures
and the response potentials that develop
dynamically within systems of these
holomorphic functions
allow me to consider particular and
collective sense structures as non-local
integrations of such functors
a collection of dynamic shapes in the
organism
this then gives me the means to
mathematically characterize not only a
particular sense
the dynamically covariant response
potentials in the structure
but also combinations of these
structures forming higher order
experience and eventually the basic
operations
of the mind the mechanism is general
and so provides the means to reason
about the full range of biophysical
behavior
from the smallest to the largest
organism
the effect described in physical terms
produces a living collaboration between
the biomechanics of flexible closed
structures
the cells and membranes of the organism
the enclosed biochemistry
and the environment a particular sense
is formed in a particular structure
it may be considered a shape upon the
surface
of the cell or membrane structure
wherever this shape occurs
independent scale there is precisely the
same sense
latent receptors are induced upon this
surface
so that the shaping will more readily
conform to its stimulus
this mechanism is the basis
of the development of memory and habit
this action refines the responsive form
of the structure so that response
potentials
may be said to form under the same
effects
the very simple in the very simplest
cases in organisms such as bacteria
this occurs upon the opposite side of
the closed structure
but it should be readily apparent that
such surfaces provide a large
combination
of potential formations and so it is
the biophysical response is diverse and
adaptable
developed in its environment in the
early stages of development and adult
plasticity
the book will be available next year if
i finish
reading for now uh what i'm planning to
do at this point
is just quickly right onto the board
some of these equations in a way that
generally stressful
so we can rewrite einstein's equation as
well known as a special relativity
equation
like so okay um
and so now that i'm i'm claiming that uh
there's this static finite
light field we can we can add
into this equation a non-linear equation
g which gives you
the unification of special and general
relativity
this of course is a very limited
equation
because nowhere in it doesn't really
talk about structure so
you know what you sort of want to do and
and this is not adequate let me
place an ad is add structure on one side
and the basis of experience on the other
side so you would have
the essential problems of nature in an
equation like this
but that that it really is viable
as as uh it apparently is
is formed so let's talk about the
what those initial conditions so the
light field
the the simplest unit for me
is the sphere the unit sphere the light
field then considered to be
a such a sphere um
if you apply this equation to the
surface of this sphere
you end up with an um this is an ideal
state of
pure purely mathematical state this is
not something that is possible
but if you apply this what you would
find
is you'd end up with gravitational mass
all around the edge okay and it's this
gravitational mass that then
sort of reduces to black holes
which generate your structure blah blah
okay um so very different sort of
cosmological view
i'm only really following this
because it seems to be just the
necessary conclusions of einstein's
method
so uh so by this means then
uh you can think of
this as the force of gravitation on the
on the sphere and then of course you end
up with your structure and you get the
whole
of general relativity
now what is this is these are equations
of open structure
there's no closed structure at this
point so where where we need to
where we need to take this is uh into
the holomorphic functions and what you
end up with is a hormone function that
looks something like this
uh forgive me if you're not familiar
with complex analysis
um and in essence what you have here
is a a holistic function
that describes a shape on the surface of
the structure
so in bacteria for example this is the
function that describes the uh
construction
the the development of latent
sensory receptors and here
this would be your motor function so
this is the respect the
response so what you end up with
is sort of you know classical uh
holomorphic
uh hyper function between
sense and response
just very briefly
obviously a lot more to say that's why i
have time for
that right now i'm happy to take
questions
i want to go back to the very beginning
a
book of the last century which was sort
of
interesting uh julian james and the
evolution of the bicameral mind
which is at some level a claim that
human consciousness has changed
the span of recorded history
here's his claiming that humans as of
1870 were capable of
the whole universe that's at some
fundamental level
and i don't see how you get there
well why not i mean the only reason the
reason you have that bus
is because of 20th century conceptions
i mean it's certainly an optimistic view
on the part of benjamin first
well i don't know that it's true now
well if it's true it's always been true
right i mean it's not that uh the claim
is simply
that the human mind can't conceive of
ideas that are sufficiently broad
to accurately characterize the world and
that the route then
benjamin purse was one of the founders
of pure mathematics
and person is simply saying the route to
that is pure mathematics
uh admittedly i mean it would take some
demonstrating
but uh if we had a theory say that
that explained uh you know
the mind the living mind and
all biophysical behaviors then wouldn't
we be close
i'll grant that but there's a there's an
if right there
well i mean uh i make a rather broader
claim
actually in my introduction which is to
say it
that it allows us a conceivable
certainty and i go to some length in the
book
to speak about uh how it's possible for
us to develop
a purely mathematical physical theory
that is um remains falsifiable
but it is of such standing
that it lasts for all time and that's a
conceivable certainty
if you there's caveat you have to
rewrite mathematical logic
uh with einstein's epistemology in mind
the structuralism i'm advocating
and uh the necessity to throw away the
uh materialist conception from which you
know everything we know is
is founded in some material basis but to
accept
that the essential properties of nature
are generally covariant as einstein said
that's the actually four i've got some
key points there but this is uh
incidentally this is benjamin purse 100
years or so before
our friend einstein and
this is a picture i rather like at the
moment
and i'll talk about this picture and
other stuff
related to the purse family uh in
january
this chat here his arms crossed here's
benjamin purse
gentleman in the middle i hope you
recognize as abraham lincoln
and this is not dan dennett
it's actually henry gold um
brock henry uh joseph uh joseph henry
uh this is a ghazi
uh guys four of these
are harvard illuminaries harvard
luminous they are
uh members of what was called the
scientific lazaroni
who founded the academy of sciences
but anyway let me move off of that
that's more historical context the
historical context is essentially here
that
um benjamin purse had a similar idea to
the to my own
and he charged his son charles
with the task at hand
and his intuition was that the recently
uh
invented hamilton cortonians
which is the foundation of complex
analysis was the way forward
and the charles tried to pursue that
route and abandoned it
his older brother james um
who died in 1906 uh died the
uh the world's export and cartonians
although
uh he never really published on this
subject
um for i believe social reasons
benjamin was a professor harvard for 50
years and james was
also a professor at harvard for 50 years
it's an interesting story which i'll
relate on the 15th of january
any other questions
a lot to take in
well i'll make a comment
i i think i probably came in on
on a subject and i didn't take
any of the prerequisites okay
oh is that how you feel right now that's
how i feel right now
well and that wouldn't be surprising
yeah
yeah i mean the book is obviously goes
into some more depth but
what i in here is sort of a
uh in your face introduction of the
basic idea you know the overview of the
overall concept i'd like to know the
prerequisites that i should take
probably though uh there might not be
any i mean in terms of in mathematical
terms
uh uh you know i will discuss
later in the book i discussed two uh
rigorous approaches to reasoning about
cell formations and structures and i use
a classical complex analysis which has
developed over the past
uh i've been fit having to maybe 200
years at this point
um and uh it actually went out of favor
when when james
purse when james mills first died
in 1909 uh
he um cortonians and
complex analysis were really out of
favor and the new vector analysis
had really started to take over in the
past
uh 20 years i guess 15 20 years
complex analysis has come back as a
subject of interest in all physics
so in general i think understanding a
little about holomorphic functions how
how hyper functions which is the
combination of these holomorphic
functions works
that would be relevant from the point of
view
of the mathematics involved i am
actually going to suggest a new geometry
it's a sort of experimental geometry
because there are some questions i have
about the broad applicability of complex
analysis for this purpose
um in terms of the epistemology involved
which is what people like to call you
know how we know anything about the
world
um i actually introduced a broader
information and
knowledge theory which sort of
more generalizes theories of knowledge
so you know an understanding of
basically what a theory of knowledge is
what it might look like
um and then i guess structuralism
which is actually a well well discussed
subject this is a refinement of existing
uh structural uh structuralist
approach um in essence all that we can
talk about in the world it says
is structure um now most
and there are a couple of forms of
structuralism
out there in use in science today
if they use an epistemology at all um
and
this is sort of the crisis that i talk
about at the beginning is that
science has ceased to adhere to good
theories of what
in the vernacular we call good theories
of knowledge and so
this argues the case very strongly for
a structuralism a structuralism that is
founded upon the covariance of nature's
essential properties
as generally cobarian and the argument
is
that this is actually a more effective
method than to be preferred
over the normal axiomatic method because
it binds premises
and this was this was what einstein was
advocating
this is what einstein advocated in uh
1916 and all of his work on the
foundations of general relativity
and of course that he sort of was
railroaded
i had he immediately came into uh
criticism in 1917
i want to say kurtzman or i
don't remember the name of head who who
claimed that einstein's theory of
general relativity
was physically vacuous you know the
consequence of that as i said
is that we
we have come to invent or endow
uh an existential status for this notion
of space-time
which einstein spoke very strongly
against and of course einstein isn't the
originator of that idea that goes back
to ernst mark
at the end of the 19th century
so um so the
the precedence for this is historical
in fact there's not a lot of current the
current
curriculum stuff that you would apart
from things like complex analysis
that you would find this kind of
view advocated in computational terms uh
bringing back
the in this forum um there are reasons
why i mean i
my original my base career is
competition
and the reason i
exclude uh since nobody's asked me i'll
ask it myself the reason i exclude
a turing computation uh has to do with
the
pure pragmatics the human brain is how
the argument runs
you know the human brain uh dissipates
watts of power and circumstances
are quite extraordinary the distribution
of the temperature across the brain is
within one degree
everywhere there are no hot spots
any any computer scientist should be
alarmed at that
and neurons don't do what the neuro the
the uh
the um uh neural networks guys want you
to believe
right neurons work together with
astrocytes
to change blood flow
they change structure that's what
they're doing
so if you do the computations right you
do the calculations
so this is our favorite number right now
we want to build computers in the
district
and our estimates and the claim is
is i believe it's a completely serious
claim but the claim is this is
comparable to the number of connections
in the brain nonsense
because because that's not what's going
on
so if you do the math by the way
this requires you to have
in a human brain 94 electron volts
per operation per
transport per storage
not hostile just no way so that uh and
this
this beast if we ever get to build one
is going to cost you
16 megawatts or so
just all right so this is the arguments
pragmatic argument
uh why um turing's uh
models of systematic computation are
necessarily excluded from biophysics
because there's no way in hell you're
ever going to build a machine with that
with that power profile you know 15 watt
power
profile just not not going to happen
um so that's sort of where
the uh that argument comes from you and
you know you
get a few people push back and say well
what about reversible computation
well um this is the notion that you can
actually get away from doing something
for nothing
um if you if i just point people to
the work of john d norton at
pennsylvania who has written adequate
papers to show that
that that's not possible
landau's principle and all of that
yeah so
was that the uh practical implications
teased at the beginning of the talk
oh well there are other practical
implications i mean given that we have a
i mean the two two things that many
people are asking questions about
machine engineering and medicine clearly
if we have a better understanding
of the role of sense in biophysics
we must be informed in medicine
just no question right we can actually
explain how it is a particular sense
forms
in biophysics medicine is aided
in terms of machine engineering if we
understand this sufficiently
well my favorite because it's the most
provocative idea
is that we can build machines that
experience
doing things i mean i i have in mind
making decisions across large scale
mathematical structures
and doing things like recognition
easily which is something that
biophysics does of
uh very low uh very low cost and the
reason is because
a recognition is essentially uh
there's no no no storage required in
biophysics
so simply a reformation of structure
and so the whole processing system
within a
uh in terms of symbolic processing
within uh within biophysics is the
formation of these structures which you
can
consider symbols and the
hyper function connection to
the response potentials that develop
are you going to ask a question at the
back
yeah but
i'll stand by my comment about five
months ago when i said about qualified
to review the book
well yeah new ideas
are unfamiliar and as a consequence
they're hard
personal love you really like one
century ago
i am very uh yes i've come to very much
appreciate the work that was done in the
formation of harvard university
around the work of benjamin purse
his motivations his intro don't agree
with all of his politics
but um he was of his time
um and um his sons
uh undertook uh um
i mean this was the mission that that
benjamin charged his son charles with
build the bridge between
uh pure mathematics and the physical
sciences
and as a consequence you know charles
made lots of great contributions
to mathematical logic he founded
um logic of semiotic theory which
is the terminology i'm i'm dropping more
more and more as because really it's
logic as a natural science
well it's not just that it's also true
but indeed and then there's
there's the whole yeah also touring
i mean charles charles uh well there's
there's there's sort of a history of
logic that extends
into the 20th century from the 19th
century
and uh charles purse and his students uh
thought against what they described as
the russellization of logic
which is basically the pursuit of the
logicist agenda
in which logic ceases to be
uh a ceases to play the role that
benjamin wanted but that is becomes a
pure mathematics
so that's it
you